[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campbell joined
by bestselling author and host of The
Rachel Cruz show Rachel Cruz and this is
your show America so give us a call at
882 5 5225 you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money and we will
tell you the truth even if it hurts your
feelings because we love you that much
and uh we appreciate all of you tuning
in today Becky is in Bristol Virginia to
kick us off Becky welcome to the Ramsey
Show H thank you uh for taking my call
sure how can we help
um well I am currently
$85,000 in debt that my husband of 30 5
years does not know
about and I have just had my old crap
moment when I overdrew my checking
account because um over 20 years ago we
had to file
bankruptcy and at that point my husband
and I separated our checking accounts
because he is a Fab and I am a spender
and I got us into that mess so now I am
door dashing I'm working my full-time
job I'm selling everything that I have
purchased trying to get out of this debt
because I do not want to tell him and I
don't want to ask him to help
me and I can't find and door Dash where
I live is not that popular because it's
just a rural
area so how much do you
make I make 38,000 a year Becky what's
the 85,000 what kind of debt is it
credit it's all credit cards wow and
what are you what are you buying like
what what what what's what's on the
bills I was buying anything and
everything I wanted if my kid wanted
something which they're now grown I
would buy them something I would if my
mom needed help I'd just give her a
credit
card okay what made you control wake up
today and go I'm done with
this uh when I overdrew my checking
account paying these minimum payments on
these credit
cards and are you paying any other bills
right now how are your finances going
with your husband if everything
separate um our house is paid for thanks
thankfully for because of because of him
and um I pay my own car
payment and cell phone bill what's your
car worth and what do you owe on
it uh I owe 15,000 on it and it's worth
about 10 and was that one of the things
you're planning on
selling I don't see how I could because
I don't have the $5,000 to make up the
difference is the 15 wrapped up in the
85 you men mentioned or is that outside
of that no no no my husband knows about
the car payment so you got 100 Grand in
debt yeah anything
else no okay okay so Becky you do
realize you're gonna have to tell
him I don't want to but you think you're
going to go to the grave and he doesn't
know this ever
happened well I would I would do just
about anything to stop it because like I
said we I got us in a really bad
situation 20 years ago and he smelled
this type of person he's not a spender
he's a saver he paid our house off early
I just can't imagine having a healthy
marriage going forward while you keep
this secret you can't yeah I mean you
you you're not your marriage will not be
where it could be ever with Secrets
right and that's Financial or otherwise
um because there's a part of you Becky
when you hold those kind of Secrets and
you're trying to be the one to fix it
all on your own which I'm not saying you
shouldn't I mean like we can get to that
discussion in a little bit but um that
that's going to come out other ways like
within your body I me like you you can't
people humans are souls we can't carry
that around it will it will come out
sideways one way or the other and so
coming clean for you Becky and not even
just for him to have the knowledge for
you it will eat you alive for you you
can't carry the secret around you it has
to be taken from the darkness of inside
of you to the light and and and it is
going to be an excruciating
conversation um but I think for the for
any way for you to move forward not just
financially but in other areas of your
life Becky you have to bring him into
this or and or someone else if you have
a good friend um who knows you both well
maybe even going to a third party first
and having them sit in with you if it's
too difficult because of you know your
history but um whatever that looks like
I mean I really would encourage you you
you have to tell
somebody and then eventually you have to
tell him and have this conversation and
and Becky and I want you to do some good
work too I'm like you know we'll get you
some John deloney Dr John deloney
material too because there's some real
stuff going on Becky like I know like
when you look at those numbers on your
screen and you realize holy crap I can't
even keep up the minimum payments with
what I'm doing that's your all crap
moment but there's a lot of other stuff
Becky going on that caused this right
and it's and I mean I don't know if
there's a level of a shopping addiction
I don't know if it's um really poor
boundaries that you've set with people a
sense of not living in reality right
like there's all these elements um that
I want you as a person to overcome
because money is just the symptom this
$85,000 in credit card debt is a symptom
of other things going on within you and
until that's fixed and until that's
addressed I mean really with a good
counselor and a therapist are you going
to heal from that be aware of that and
be able to make different decisions day
in and day out and um and I wish there
was an easy button I wish there was an
easy button but it it's going to be a
season for you guys a season of
financially paying this back whatever
that looks like and however you guys
decide within your marriage um but it's
also going to be a season of rebuilding
trust cuz trust will be broken it's been
broken um and hard conversations there I
mean it's it's going to be it's going to
be painful but it is the way to Healing
Becky that is the way to heal it is not
to hold this and try to fix it
yourself
okay I'm so I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
you're you're in this and I know there's
probably so much shame and guilt and
regret that you have um but moving
forward for you to to be able to take
that weight off healing has to happen
and it can't happen on your own it
really can't we have to have other
people around us and I think good
professionals yeah as well and long term
we have to get your husband back to
husband mode instead of roommate mode
one of the best parts of marriage and
one of the hardest parts is having the
accountability of a spouse and I think
that could have helped a lot of this if
there was transparency in the finances
and him saying hey you need to cut up
that card remember we don't use that
anymore we got burnt we went through
bankruptcy 20 years ago we don't want
that to happen again and so I think you
need accountability right now it may not
be your husband cuz there's already a
lack of trust there but we need
accountability from other people you've
been doing this alone and keep in the
secret and how old are you I'm 50 you're
50 so you have a lot of years left Becky
I'm like you have a whole second part of
life we've seen bigger SC numbers yes to
be lived and I we want that for you and
more and and I want that for you more
than just the money side I want this
fixed for you but Becky I'm like man
there's there's so much for you to heal
from and your story what brought you
here um and I really want you to be able
to do that if you hold on the line
Christian's going to pick up and we'll
give you a bunch of uh Dr John Jone's um
books and different materials cuz I
think walking through that and kind of
opening the door to that part of the
world um and understanding yourself I
think is big and Christian put my book
know yourself know your money in there
as well but um we just want to get you
some good resources Becky and push into
this don't sweep it under the rug don't
try to fix it yourself do the hard work
it's hard but that's where the healing
is this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys ramsy solution started small
and grew fast because of that rapid
growth there were times when our systems
slowed us down that's why we switched to
net Suite it works for us and it'll help
your business too whether you're
starting on a card table like I did or
you're well on your way to becoming a
multi-million doll company netw site can
scale with you and help you communicate
and plan better because you know your
day-to-day up and down and sideways but
accounting analytics and supply chain
are on another level so maybe you're
just not techsavvy that can be okay net
Suite will help at your speed and
whatever your situation more than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business
business better so check out netw Suite
today and find out how they can help you
become the business you want to be 5 or
30 years from now and right now you can
download netsuite's free kpi checklist
designed to give you consistently
excellent performance at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz this
hour open phones at
5225 Ben is up next in South Carolina
Ben welcome to the
show hey thank you for having me sure
how can Rachel and I help
today
so my wife and I discovered last year
when my mother-in-law went in the
hospital that my mother-in-law had 100K
or more in debt and so now she's in a
postacute care facility she's not able
to walk she just got approved for
disability and you know the debt still
there so we've been back and forth on
just like I think
uh bankruptcy is the only way for her um
to get out of that
because no income and on disability I I
don't see a way of her getting rid of a
100K it's just is there any other
solution does she have assets does she
have a
home uh no she had a car but my wife had
to get durable power of attorney which
lets her uh move assets and make medical
calls it doesn't financially tie us to
her but um whenever she's not able to
make calls or manage assets we can move
them so she had a car and that was the
only thing of value that she had um and
my wife had that put into my wife's name
so that that way we could cancel the
bills uh for insurance and everything it
was paid off but we had to cancel like
insurance and taxes and everything so
that a car that's not being driven isn't
being
paid what kind of debt is the
100,000 um credit cards
microtransactions little loans it I I
don't know how much medical debt is now
being accured because this was the debt
before she was in the
hospital how old is she 55 and do you
know how much the disability payments
will
be I don't know she just got approved
for it and so we're still looking at
like setting that
up and what's her plan moving forward W
how long will she be in this K versus
being out on her own like what's what's
the time
frame um that's hard to say uh my wife
and I as bad as it sounds are kind of of
the negative opinion that this might be
permanent um but what happened what's
wrong what what's what's going on with
her health so she wasn't very healthy to
start with before she went into the
hospital she was on 27 medications she
was 300 something pounds and under 5
foot tall she had heart problems she
went to the hospital because she had an
infection in her heart and had to have
an aortic valve replacement and the
surgeon said that she'd never seen that
much infection in her heart and so her
blood sugar at the time her regular
blood sugar was like
400 so so it's a miracle she's even
alive right now uh it was a miracle she
was alive before that yes um but she's
she's yeah right now she is healthy to
the point of like we're not worried
about infection or anything all the
stuff's under control in the facility
she's as healthy as she's ever been but
she's not able to walk is the issue um
it's just a matter of she needs to get
physical therapy and they canceled that
because they weren't seeing they would
saw her Plateau on her progress so they
canceled it um it's just a very not very
good situation so motivation lacking
we've gotten her to therapy on a t thing
and
so we think that Solutions like she's
we've had to when we discovered how bad
she was in debt um my wife's
grandparents cut her out of the will
because I mean you're not going to leave
irons all this misbehavior yeah well
I'll answer this as if I was in your
shoes and I'm sorry you guys are going
through this has your wife wife had a
hard conversation with mom to give her
the reality of where things are at we've
kind of had the reality check and I even
spoke to her just a few hours ago of
like no more credit cards no lotto
tickets nothing after this does your
wife have power of attorney for the
financial part of her life does she have
all access to the bank accounts that um
she's gotten some access just from
passwords and everything that her
mothers s her do but uh we don't we
aren't financially tied to her which is
what we've been avoiding because we
we're big fans of the ramsy stuff so we
are doing very well in our lifestyles um
better than I've watched your videos uh
George on like where you should be in
life at certain ages we're 27 we're
about double of what your uh goals
should be awesome so we're doing well
but I'm not going to my wife and I agree
we're not going to financially
ourselves to pay off I would never
suggest that some bad choices no but I
think it may be helpful to have the
ability to cut her off from making this
worse and if she's unable I I can see
her just at home if she only has access
to phone and laptop and she's stuck
there just continuing this spending out
of emotion and depression so here's what
I would do if I was in your shoes man I
would pull her credit report to get a
full picture of all the debt she owes
who she owes it to what the amounts are
then I would begin the process of
contacting all these creditors and
explaining her situation very honestly
this woman is broke she's on disability
she is lucky to be alive she can't pay
these
debts M and many of them are going to go
to collections and that's just this the
sad truth of it there may not be a
situation where she just goes and pays
off 100,000 in debt at this point of her
life and at this
age so you would say do that over
bankruptcy I think this is the start is
is pulling the credit report contact
creditors explain and see what they say
what they're willing to do what they're
to work with her on what they're willing
to forgive and then figure out what is
her disability income and how do we
manage her future expenses so that this
problem doesn't get worse and so helping
her get on that budget and that that's
where I think the control comes in where
you guys have to kind of help her manage
this you're not hitching Your Wagon to
her financially but I think she
obviously needs some help here and it
may be your wife's doing um because of
the daughter mom
relationship to have those
conversations I understand but that's as
much as you can do as much as you want
to help her and get her out of the debt
I mean she may end up going through
bankruptcy I hope it doesn't happen but
that's a very real possibility at her
stage with this amount of debt and her
inability work anything I mean cuz she's
got no savings no retirement she's
nothing but again bankruptcy while it
may solve her debt problem we still have
to think about how is she going to
survive forward that's it yeah I mean it
it screws up your C I mean you're just
you know for for for a getting her on
board with this is that she's kind of
lived life as a hoarder which is how
she's accumulated the debt without
having anything of value she doesn't
have a choice anymore she's opted out of
having options yeah but she but it is to
the end of the day though what's so hard
about this is she could choose to go on
a laptop open a credit card and do it
right I'm like cuz I don't want Ben I
don't want you guys to feel like you
then have to be the parents and control
every little aspect of her to save her
her grandparents have done that and
there's a point that cut her to it yeah
there I mean and it sounds hard harsh
and it but there's there's nothing in
your ability to be able to control every
little behavior of someone else you just
can't and for her she I mean there there
might be a reality where she faces the
music and truly it's it's bankruptcy but
we don't want you know like as much as
we can avoid that for someone we try
every other possibility than just going
down that road um but it's it's hard
been and and and it is
that it's such a delicate balance of
family of saying she's
and you know I know she's not in great
health so I don't know how obviously how
long she has but I mean it could be
another three decades and and it and it
you and your wife have to yeah come it
sounds like you guys are very much on
the same page but figure out what are
our boundaries like where's the point
that we draw a boundary that we've tried
to help as much as we can but there's
only so much that that you can do and
the truth is she may go to the grave and
still owe this debt and that's when it
gets forgiven as long as none of it's in
y'all's name it's not going to get
passed on to you it'll go against your
estate which there are no assets and so
the debt will just get eaten by these
creditors so that's the truth it's a sad
truth of the matter and I'm sorry you
guys are going through this but I'm also
I'm proud of you guys you've changed
your family tree just by going that's
not going to be us and you've had great
boundaries yes um already to by ening
and propping her lifestyle up you guys
are doing the right thing and I'm sorry
you had to grow up so fast this way but
I'm wishing you guys and her the best
with her help financial situation Ben
that's a really hard thing to do but
again we we can't change people as much
as you want to help her she's got to
face the music at some point and that
that's going to have consequences either
way this is the ramsy
[Applause]
[Music]
show
hey guys you know this but I'll say it
anyway college is freaking expensive and
student loans are out of control the
average private student loan debt in
2023 was
$55,000 so if you're in over your head
with private student loan debt don't
beat yourself up look we've all made
mistakes with money in the past what
matters is doing something about it now
so if you're in distress with private
student loans that's private not federal
student loans call Y refi y refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay to learn
more about this custom refinancing
option call
8442 Ramsey or or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey welcome back to the Ramsey Show
I'm camel joined by Rachel Cruz open
phones at
5225 well Rachel I don't know what
you're doing this weekend but you know
I'll be I'll be on the couch maybe with
some buffalo wings watching the big game
oh looking for Taylor Swift came Sunday
me too George that's really any that's
the only reason we are A House Divided
my conspiracy theory is that Taylor and
Travis are dating so that more nonf
football fans will watch the game okay
people keep say we can talk I don't want
to talk about this conspiracy I think
it's that is so stupid she needs she
does not need that and the NFL's got to
fixel you know they got to figure it out
money talks Rachel you pay me $40
million I might date a football player f
is this the first conspiracy that you
haven't wanted to talk about that's true
Rachel's like I'm shutting this
conspiracy down here's the thing a
conspiracy is only something that's like
oh wow that's so like that would be
crazy like this whole like couples get
together like this happens a lot in
Hollywood but she doesn't need it
anyways we're getting off topic all
right well we're here to talk about
money Rachel so here's the the trivia
game we're going to play and she's going
to vote for Biden too so everyone's like
oh my God it's like a political thing we
all know it Isel all know that we all
know that already that's not a
conspiracy I just pushed the button so
easily and I just Rachel just went just
Unwound okay I'm done I'm done go we're
going to play a game around Super Bowl
costs okay play a little over under so
I'm going to name something you tell me
what you think it costs as it relates to
the Super Bowl okay flights from any
City Nationwide to Las Vegas what do you
think the flights are costing one flight
one way let's say round trip round trip
flight I'm going to say you would pay
I'm going to go three grand wow you're
over oh it says 300 to over $1,000
depending on how close and flight ail I
was thinking like 1,200 one way cuz I
feel like they would have so th000 bucks
for flights let's move on to hotels now
U most of them are sold out but
Staybridge Suites is one of the only
ones that has available rooms what do
you think get cost for average per
night um how far out is this in the city
do you have do you have geographical
location it says it's near the venue
that's all it says oh gosh I mean I bet
you pay I
mean 700 you are spot on
696 I'm going to call that a win all
right so 1,000 bucks for Flight 700 for
the hotel and now what about a resort
near the venue oh you're you'll go uh
11100 1377 man you're a little under on
that one okay okay okay and hotels
outside of the city that are more
available it's still 200 bucks to 650
for one of those okay now let's get to
the tickets this is the priciest part
what do you think the average ticket
price is for the Super Bowl average
right now we're talking secondary
markets if you just went and you wanted
to buy one right now I'm going to
say
12,000 gosh she's good what what is it
105 up to 12
is the range on the secondary Market am
I Super Bowl expert oh my gosh you
should go like prices right you guess
the price of like Clorox and Rachel get
I I actually be really good at that okay
obviously look how good I'm doing here
the dinette set yeah there you go okay
uh most affordable ticket what do you
think that is so that was average what
do you think the most affordable ticket
is right now I bet you could I bet you
could watch the Super Bowl live for I'm
going to go s
7,000 a little under give me one one
more eight 75 7500 bucks for the most
affordable ticket and most of them right
now for least expensive are ranging
after fees from 7,800 up to 9,300 okay
okay so let's do the math now let's add
it all up let's say the flights are
1,000 bucks the hotel 700 bucks let's
say you just stayed one night somehow
you made that happen that's 1,700
already already now the actual ticket
you're talking let's say that's 103 mhm
this hurts my brain you're yeah I wasn't
doing the math sorry were you wanting me
to do the math well 103 plus 1,700 that
puts it at 12 okay so you're 12 Grand
you're 12 Grand in without anything for
somebody that doesn't like know this
world very well that's reasonable to you
um I would have guessed it probably
would have been higher like if you just
said what would a knight to stay that
doesn't include food and go to the Super
Bowl I kind of thought you gu like 15
yeah I feel I feel like it would have
been higher W well for a perspective
Super Bowl 57 average ticket price was
57.95 so I don't know if it's inflation
or what or this is a big game because of
you know some celebrities that might be
present Tay Tay admit it there was a lot
of hype around this one comparatively oh
sure yeah yeah yeah yeah I've never seen
so much just press and news about
football players Amilia asked what time
the Chiefs kick off when your
eight-year-old asks you're like oh
they've been talking at School
apparently about it and all the girls
school talk for an 8-year-old in third
grade yes goodness gracious I know now
I'm sure the boys like actually enjoy
the football part of it would you guys
ever take the kids and go see the Super
Bowl no not worth it I don't think I
care about the Super Bowl that much for
$155,000 I think well I I did an
Instagram reel about this you can take a
a trip for two a cruise seven night
cruise for two in a junior suite with a
balcony to the Bahamas yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's do that and it was 6500 bucks
oh gosh I'm like I'd rather do that
twice even you we compared it to used
cars you could buy $10,000 I'm like
would I rather have an upgrade to the
car or you know or fully funding a Roth
IRA as boring as I am you know that's
what I would do six grand and here's the
thing and again we're not the most
sports loving host speak for yourself I
of the ramsy show I love a play action
pass when I see one right one of my
favorite passes there is
come on the two-point conversion I live
for that I mean it's yeah the stress the
stress is high I just think it's
sometimes it's just more fun to be in
the comfort of your own home I agree
well can I be honest I've been to one
NFL game and the whole time I was just
looking at the giant screen because I
could not see what was happening on the
field and I went I could just be doing
this at home I could without grown men
yelling all around me right right and
also my Patriots lost to the Titans in a
bad way oh yeah like Brady just got
spanked out there good it was not fun no
good well oh man there you go if you're
going to the game uh good luck budget
for it uh I I prefer I I'm fine with
fomo on this one yes for sure no I'm
good watch an usher from my living room
there we go that's why I do it half time
and the commercials have been mediocre I
feel like in the past few years I'm
really hoping for a if you're dropping
Millions on these commercials and
dropping a good stat I thought that was
going to be part of this seg what
commercial cost yes dang next year
hoping every dollar will have a
commercial next year's Super Bowl maybe
we can crowdfund it cuz Dave's not going
to pay a bajillion dollars for 30C spot
but if everyone pitches in we can get
every dollar in front of America there
you go get get America budgeting let do
what we need it's what we I do wonder
how much debt people will be in due to
the Super Bowl due to all the costs
involved yeah and it's just one of those
things that again I was about to compare
it to a wedding I don't know why cuz
it's like that one day event type thing
very different than a Super Bowl don't
get mad at me in the comments spending
15 grand on a game versus what a wedding
cost it makes weddings look cheap yeah
right so I'm like it is it's such a um I
don't know we're such a culture of
experience that it's almost like you
lose this like gauge of reality
sometimes and you just you're just all
in you're just solely focused on yeah
that's what we're going to do we're
going to go the Super Bowl that's what
we're going to do now if you can afford
it and it's a on the bucket list or your
team's playing and you know and you want
to go it's great like B step seven
living your best life and 15 grand is
not going to ruin your financial world
I'm not mad at you no but man it could
it could go far that amount of money
George true and truu two cruises one
thing I didn't realize when you're live
at the game there's no commentary I
didn't realize how much I needed that to
explain what's happening the the pass
action what' you say play action pass R
get it right don't offend any
footballers out there so I prefer the
commentary I want to be able to get up
and go to the bathroom when I want you
know and not I think you can do that at
a game yeah but you're crawling over
people there's a line excuse me and
everyone's like they're about to kick
the field goal and GE like I got to go
and there are few darker places in the
world than a men's bathroom at a
sporting event Rachel have you been to
one of
these I have not actually they give them
like they give them like a trough and
it's just a freefor all it's disgusting
in there I have very big opinions on
your yeah I can't I think it's gross
that's gross we'll save that for another
time that's gross but hey enjoy the game
hopefully you're watching from home you
did it on a bud okay go for real though
Chiefs or um 49ers I'm going you know
why T well Blake Thompson who runs the
Ramy network is the biggest Chiefs fan I
know basically our boss on the show I
don't want our boss in a bad mood
essentially oh no deana's oh San
Francisco 49 Warehouse divided Winston's
going 49ers I'm going Chiefs Caroline's
going 49ers I'm going milila Kansas City
Charles Kansas City at the end of the
day Rachel and I are team Taylor and
that's the truth who cares about the
sport I'm all for it I'm here for the
queso this is the Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to church Hill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
joined by Rachel Cruz I'm George camel
open phones at
88255 225 well our team is starting to
get geared up for a brand new event
happening May 10th and 11th it's called
Total Money Makeover weekend and I know
there's millions of of you out there
you've been list for a while but you
haven't really followed the stuff you
maybe been ramsy is maybe you followed
it to a tea and now you got a journey
ahead of you of just investing and
Building Wealth and you need a little
pep in your step well in just one
weekend you're going to get that you're
going to get a crash course on
everything we teach about money all of
the Ramsey personalities will be there
including Dave Ramsey brand new content
on budgeting beating debt investing and
so much more so regardless of where
you're at in your financial Journey this
is going to light a fire under your butt
to keep making progress we're going to
have live Q&A throughout the weekend so
bring your questions we'll do a live
smart money happy hour recording with
met Jonah out in the lobby and he said
he wants to be there for the for the
recording people are very excited about
the smart money happy hour they may come
just for that it may just be the only
reason people come we do have a good
time so make plans to be there get it in
the budget plan the flights the lodging
all the good stuff and make a trip to
Nashville to see us in May early bird
tickets start at just 99 bucks that's an
amazing deal for a weekend event and the
tickets will go up over time so get them
now the Ramsey Event Center holds about
2400 people so this event will sell out
get your tickets now at ramsy
solutions.com
events Gavin is up next in Raleigh North
Carolina Gavin welcome to the
show hello good afternoon thanks for
taking my call sure what's going on so
uh I'm getting deployed here in the next
few months um and I don't really have
many expenses so I should come back with
a decent chunk of money and I'm just
curious on what I should do with
wow what branch are you I'm a marine
okay thanks for your service Gavin
that's thank you guys that's amazing um
how old are you so I'm 20 years old um
I've been in for I'm going on my third
year now I left when I was
17 um yeah wow what are your what are
your future goals as far as finances
go um I would like to be financially
free you know as soon as it's possible
but uh I do I take my finances pretty
serious so you know I just I'm not sure
if I should come back and try to invest
into some real estate with my father or
put it in different you know funds or a
CD or because I come back from
deployment and I'll have about a year
and a half two years left before my
contract is over so yeah okay so how
much savings are we talking
about
ballet depending on how long where we
are and whatever it could be between 25
to 35,000
okay and you have no debt um I have
about $2,000 in credit card debt um you
know just young young you know whatever
and then I have about $88,500 in a raw
Ira that gets taken out of my paycheck
automatically um and it is matched 5% by
the military I have about 6,500 in a
brokerage account and $5,000 cash
savings account okay well I'm going to
give you advice and I hope you take it I
would pay the credit card off today and
then I'd cut it up you'll still have
three grand in cash and then you can
start using every single dollar coming
in to save up and build wealth and you
need to have a I know you won't have
many expenses but I would have an
emergency fund there to protect you um
and that may look like $5,000 for you
while you're
deployed okay for three to six months of
expenses yeah and just put that in a
high yield savings account Gavin so you
can get to it if you need it um but I
would just yeah I would just set that
money in there and I wouldn't make any
big decisions until you're home um right
and even you know I mean you know you're
so young which is great that you're
starting this process but even you know
just you know being patient till you're
you're you're out which will be another
two years um and then until you go and
you know whether you choose to get back
in I don't know what that looks like or
go get a job but by that point is when
you can actually say okay where do I
want to settle in do I want to I would
buy a house for yourself before I'd go
invest in real estate uh we want to
start doing retirement you know you
start kind of those processes but I
wouldn't worry too much about that right
now a part of me would just save money
um and and Gavin you know we talked to a
lot of um military out there and we're
so appreciative of everyone out there
that serves our country and the hard
thing is is what we see outside of so
many military bases is these payday
loans so much
they on the
military staying away from all of that
too um and just kind of have a hard Line
in the Sand for yourself and not get
roped into something even your friends
and the cars they're driving like
there's going to be a lot of Temptation
in the next few years and so if you can
just keep the blinders on you're already
doing such a great job on the investing
side and so just making sure you dial
that back and part of that is cutting up
the card cuz truly you don't need a
credit card MH you're so smart at this
young age you're going to be just using
your own money to live your financial
life so here's the steps pay off the
credit card today cut it up rebuild that
emergency fund then invest 15% of all
future income and you can do that with
that Roth IRA you can do that with other
retirement plans you may have access to
and then beyond that I would just save
up as much as you can in that high yield
savings account that Rachel talked about
so that when you come back from
deployment you've got you know 20 30 40
Grand in the bank and you've been
investing for the future and I'm telling
you at 20 years old you're going to be a
multi
multimillionaire retirement age and what
what do you think because I kind of feel
like I wouldn't I wouldn't worry about
investing too much while you're deployed
when you come back be looking into that
cuz I would want a lot of cash coming
back home because that transition coming
home and kind of figuring out where
you're going to go in the next year or
two I want as much cash as possible to
have all the options that I want and not
tied up in retirement yet and then once
that's kind of settled then it's kind of
that we call this baby step 3B guy where
you some people choose to save up down
payment while investing some some people
invest nothing to get the down payment
faster and so that's the the tension
here and it's not even a down payment
necessarily but it is like okay I have
this money during this transition of
figuring out what do I want to do I
don't know that always just makes me
feel safe just to have that well you
might need a a car once you get back you
know you might need a deposit for a
place to live and so that there is going
to be a lot more expenses than you have
now so it's the more cash you have
stacked up the better you won't regret
that but I would not get into real
estate investing with your Dad yet I
would wait and get your own place get
that place paid off and then work on
saving up cash for an investment
property down the line but you're 20 you
have so much time so don't feel like I'm
24 I still don't own a house breathe
you're doing great you're just so driven
that it's hard to almost pump the brakes
and just enjoy
life thank you guys yeah thank you so
much for your service again impressive
aby's in fville Arkansas Abby welcome
welcome to the show hey guys thank you
so much for taking my call I appreciate
it sure how can we help yeah so um I'll
give my question first and then some
context if you need it so um me and my
husband recently took on some medical
debt some very unexpected medical debt
and we have some existing credit card
debt which for the past year or so we've
been trying to just attack with as much
as we possibly could and so this medical
debt um has some of it has kind of
started to go to collections pretty
pretty quickly and I guess my biggest
question is should I I've heard that
medical debt when it goes to collections
um doesn't hurt you like your credit
score or anything I could be wrong about
that um so I'm wondering if I should let
it go to collections kind of talk it
down to a smaller amount while
continuing to attack the credit card
debt or if I should take another
approach the debt how much how much do
you guys have in medical debt um it's
about $99,000 okay and how much in
credit card debt about 29
th000 29,000 in credit card debt what
were you guys buying yes um yeah so it
was a mix of we did a kitchen renovation
and we didn't put that on a credit card
we did it on a helck um and so but
that's all kind of mixed together credit
card debt helck debt okay and how much
is the how much is just the credit cards
just credit cards um 18,000 probably
okay and it was is that just
lifestyle yeah it was lifestyle it was
Christmas
vacation the American way yeah totally
what do you guys make um we make um my
husband Nets about 4,600 a month and I
net 2,300 a month okay you guys can
tackle this quickly I would not let the
medical debt just go to collections the
problem is they're not going to settle
and negotiate when this debt is so fresh
it would have to be years old and so I
would just get it current and make plans
to pay it off and use that debt snowball
smallest to largest balance you guys
make great money what we need to do
ratchet down or spending not trying to C
the credit cards Abby cut them up be
done with it be done with this and
really focus why we got here in the
first place cuz until you fix yourselves
you're going to see this continue to
Bubble Up be back right to where you
started we don't want that for you this
has been another hour in the books of
the Ramsey show my thanks to Rachel Cruz
all the folks in the booth and you
America we'll be back before you
[Music]
know
oh
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campbell joined
by Rachel Cruz and this is your show
America so give us a call at
5225 we'll show you the right Next Step
you need to take with your life and your
money Christian kicks us off this hour
and Omaha Nebraska Christian what's
going
on he um how you doing we're doing great
how can we
help um so over the last couple days uh
I lost my job and just trying
to figure out the best way to move
forward what
happened um it was just a disagreement
uh between me and my manager and I think
it was just a clash of personalities
really but and so your manager just like
you're
fired yeah pretty much what were you
doing I was an it okay what were you
making uh
58 uh a year and were there any
conversations about like was this
straight firing no severance nothing
just
done yeah I as far as I know I got my
list paycheck this morning okay are you
single how long were you there
for uh just s so I'm married um and my
wife brings in some money but I was only
there we moved here to Nebraska in
May was it for the
job uh yeah so it was for work for both
of us actually okay so you've been there
less than a year and now it's just your
wife's income what does she make uh
35 all right have you started looking
for jobs already are there other
opportunities in your area in it it
seems so I've heard back from a few good
so okay well hopefully we get you back
working in it very soon in the meantime
we've got to figure out how to survive
until the next thing happens so what are
your monthly expenses right now have you
guys sat down with a budget to go okay
here's what it's going to take to run
the house for the next month in the next
three
months um not specifically like we I pay
attention into what's in our bank
account um and then we do but we do have
a
mortgage um and then food is and gas is
really all it is right now okay so this
is what we call Storm mode and so when
you sit down to do your budget we're
going to gift you every dollar premium
which is going to help it's going to
connect to your bank account track
transactions there's a paycheck planning
tool that you can use to make sure that
you've got enough money coming in to
cover all the bills that are coming up
and so what you I want you and your wife
to do is sit down tonight and lay out
every single expense print out the bank
statement do whatever you got to do and
lay out exactly what you need not what
you want what you need to cover your
budget for the month and Rachel what are
some of the things they need to look out
for in that budget well just know as
you're pulling those numbers Christian
this was numbers that you guys were
living off of before a budget and you
made over double so you're probably
going to be yeah uh spending more
because it wasn't very much on purpose
and so when you guys look do you guys
have
kids uh no okay just you guys so yeah I
mean I would look and say okay here's
here's what it costs for um us grocery
wise uh restaurants lights
utilities um you know when you look at
uh subscriptions like anything that is
coming out of your checking account I
want you to write those numbers down and
again this is before you've budgeted so
I mean I don't know if you spent 700 a
month at a grocery store just know it's
you two and that wasn't on a budget so
try to bring that down to to 400 right I
mean like do what you can to limit as
much expenses as possible for you guys
during this time because you know just
maybe a month or so before you
transition in and so just know that if
you cut things now it doesn't mean that
they're going to be forever but for this
time period because I don't want you
guys going into debt I don't want
anything like that to be happening
because that's going to cause more
stress but I think having these numbers
down and getting a good idea of okay
here's here's the paycheck for next
month here are expenses and then if
there are gaps Christian between now and
you getting a job I mean that may mean
you're picking up an hourly job
somewhere and doing what you have to do
even though it's not the job and you may
feel overqualified for it but the idea
is staying afloat with your food shelter
utilities and transportation and that
would be that that would be the biggest
thing so as you're talking to these
other companies do you think the
transition getting a new job will be
fairly quick would you say um I hope so
I'm doing some interviews soon okay
that's great yeah yeah well do you guys
have any
debt uh we have a mortgage and we just
paid off our car just last month great
oh good so no other debt except mortgage
correct any
savings uh we have uh the $1,000
emergency fund and then about 3,000 on
top of that okay great yeah I mean and
this is a time that if you have to use
that emergency fund that's what it's for
I mean job loss is one of those that we
list out but if you can avoid it and do
what you can not to touch it that would
be ideal but if you need to dip in and
you know get a get some money out of
that emergency fund that's what it's
there for but it won't be there forever
and it's not a big one right it's just
to really cover those really major
things so if you can in the meantime
Again cover the basic expenses um but
hopefully it won't be too long Christian
I I me I feel hopeful for you I think
you're in a great um sector of looking
for a job and the job market and all of
that so I just I don't know I just feel
like there there's a lot of Hope there
thank you and in the meantime you may
you know even outside of a retail job
you can download these apps like door
Dash and instacart and Uber Eats and go
to your local pizza place and deliver
pizzas just for a few weeks until you
land that next thing until that next
paycheck comes in uh that would be very
wise and I know that's hard for a lot of
people to do to kind of swallow your
pride and do a job you'd rather not be
doing and making these sacrifices but
this is what it looks like to take care
of your
family yeah I actually did do
in college so I'm trying to there you go
yeah and you can make 15 20 bucks an
hour um you know and and tips and all
that so I think it's uh you're going to
be back on your feet with a great field
like it um in your area it sounds like
you'll be back in no time but this is
the time to just go we got to live on
the rice and beans going scorched Earth
for a little while until we're back in
the clear and have some stability yeah
and whenever there's a situation like
this with a job loss and especially due
to a disagreements I think it's always
Fair Christian that yeah your your boss
could have just been a complete jerk
like and that you know unreasonable
there's people like that out there and
maybe that was him and that's fine but I
think there's always good introspective
work to go back through and say okay
what what what part did I play in this
what did that look like and to learn in
that because this isn't Christian but I
remember talking to somebody I think you
I may have been hosting with you and
they had had like four jobs in like 9
months or like it was
very extreme like okay there's kind of a
you know the similar pattern that we're
seeing a common denominator which was
the caller you know and I'm like hm
that's interesting that four people
couldn't get along with you four
different bosses um so again that's a TA
that's a Tay Tay moment I'm not saying
that's you high I'm the problem it's me
be I'm not saying that's you but but
those moments in life and in any kind of
conflict I think it's always good just
to do a little bit of that kind of okay
let's let's flush that back out what can
I learn from this too yeah but we know
science shows the job loss has very
similar effects to like a death like
you're grieving something that was near
and dear to your heart that protected
you that provided for you and so you
have to grieve it too and move on with
confidence that that was just a blip
it'll be a memory soon enough my friend
this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that chm
she can help other families who need it
and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz if
you enjoy this show you might enjoy
another show that Rachel and I co-host
called smart money happy hour fun
episode that launched this week about
the cost of love going up with
relationships with dating apps and uh
was hilarious I learned a lot so if you
want a good laugh and uh listen to it
with your with your loved one or if
you're single we have many single people
yeah there was a lot a lot of content
there for producer Skyler was single and
so she filled Us in on the current
status of the dating world and Rachel it
was I was very glad to just be married
and done with that the amount of
requests for ramsy dating apps people
want the ramsy dating and we will never
do it I don't want to be tied to that
there's too many creeps out there I
can't vouch for these people now if
Rachel and I got to approve every single
person that came onto the app what if we
were the
matchmakers I've match I've prum service
and they got married have you ever match
I don't think I've ever ventured that
far okay
butel one that's the premium version of
the dating app you can get Rachel to be
the Matchmaker this is actually not the
worst idea all right on to bigger and
better things the ramsy show question of
the day is brought to you by neighborly
your hub for home services from repairs
and maintenance to Home Improvement
projects winter can bring some
challenges for homeowners so check out
their helpful winter checklist you can
get it for free at neighborly
docomo passed away and I've inherited
what my father would have received my
husband and I are always arguing because
I don't want to touch the money unless
we purchase a house or invest it to
secure our family's future we are not
responsible when it comes to money we
have saved an emergency fund of $10,000
and in less than 7 months it was gone my
husband has always wanted to start a
business and now that we have a cushion
he wants to quit his job I asked him to
build um some of some clientele before
quitting his job because I know that he
will use the inheritance to pay our
bills and living expenses and I'm not
okay with this how do we move
forward well I think Grace has a lot of
wisdom here she's first of all
self-aware to say we are not responsible
with money and then she says is um I
know he'll use this money to basically
just live our life and that starting
this business is not smart he's got to
build some clientele and I would agree
with that that you shouldn't just up and
quit your job and then hope because
you've got this fund over here that you
can blow that's right the problem is
Grace is that there's obviously been a
pattern here that's occurred with how
you guys live with money the fact that
you Sav 10,000 which is great but then
you spent it all so so the pattern of
money is what needs to be addressed and
so that can be you know pattern that you
have that your husband has but either
way that's the core of the issue here is
that um the way you guys have handle
money in the past will repeat itself
unless you guys change course and so
that's what has to be addressed in my
opinion yeah but how do we move forward
it's more relational than it is
financial we don't know the amount of
The Inheritance we don't know if they
have debt their income all of that but I
would uh I would hit pause on touching
this inheritance for a long time until
we're on the same page yep and the value
system that's what always gets couples
that's where the arguing comes it's not
usually about the money it's the fact
that how we see life and the way we want
to do life is different and that will
cause conflict if you're not on the same
page so um yeah I mean even that's
getting with a with a marriage counselor
or a therapist and you guys working out
hey what do we want our life to look
like that's the bigger question here and
money is just the tool to create that
well there's an interesting piece of
this I want your take Rachel if you get
the inheritance but you're married to
Winston how does that obviously it's our
money but there's still a piece of it
where you have to be a good Steward of
the inheritance of that Legacy that was
passed down to you yeah and so it can't
just be think Winston's like well I
always wanted to start this business so
I'm going to use that money it's still
money that was given to you to use for
your family yes I mean I I see it still
as it's come into our family unit but I
think naturally you're going to feel I
think a level of responsibility a little
bit more emotionally yeah I mean I would
say the same is true um you know
Winston's grandfather was very generous
and um he loved some things to the
grandkids and when that happened I I
leaned more on Winston of hey what do
you think because it's his grandfather
like right there's a natural take there
like you both get a vote but OB
absolutely but I think there's yeah I
don't know I feel that way yeah but you
both but you both have equal say in it I
mean it would be unfair to say well I'm
going to go do whatever I want with this
money because it was on my side of the
family that feels that's not that's not
a team aspect right that's perspective
you want but that's the most interesting
part of this question on top of the
relational aspect of just getting on the
same page about what we're going to do
with this but I would not go blow it on
some hairbrain business idea no no no no
no whenever you want to transition into
into a business like that we always say
the most ideal way to do that is to have
some footing that you can actually
support yourself there so that it's not
this big stressful thing right cuz
starting a new business that's a
blessing like that that's such a gift
even at Ramsey if we launch something
new we don't just go launch it we test
it we verify it we get the team the
resources and we do it with cash and so
that's very smart all right Amy is on
the line in San Francisco Amy welcome to
the
show thank you thanks for having me sure
um I was hoping to get your advice
basically my question is uh is my family
doing okay financially or should we be
working harder and sacrificing more
Now to create a stable future I've been
listening to the show for two months and
I'm just kind of like all in and my
husband and I kind of disagree about
like the intensity we need to be going
at right now okay so how much debt do
you guys
have we have 24,000 in my student
loans and then our mortgage is
223,000 okay and how much do you guys
make a
year
130 okay how old are you
to I'm 37 he's 40 okay and do you both
want to pay off debt are you in
agreement on the goal or is just the
process the part you're not agreeing
on yeah we're on agreement on the goal
um it's sort of like I think it really
comes back to like our childhoods like I
was poor growing up I think I kind of
operate from um sort of like um scarcity
mentality it's never going to be enough
kind of thing and he doesn't have that
he's pretty content with where we are he
thinks we're doing fine and um you know
I'm thinking of getting a second job to
pay off the debt faster you know I get
really excited about if I make double
mortgage payments for six years I can
have my house paid off and this will be
great so he wants to chip away at the
debt and you want to take a sludgehammer
to
it yeah you guys any get really
excited yeah we have 27,000 in checking
and we have retirement accounts okay and
uh 5,000 in the money market account
okay but if we knocked out the student
loan today with the money and checking
you guys would be completely debt free
and you'd be on your way to saving up an
emergency
fund yes what would you what would he
say if you told them that hey I want to
use the money in checking we'll then
save up or make 130k we'll save up that
emergency fund back up to 25k and then
we'll begin investing and attacking the
mortgage he'd be good with that I just
made
$30,000 of payment to my student loan uh
the last two months since I've been
listening to the
show we're attacking it um pretty hard
he kind of wants to do mayy step two
first or three first I mean and save up
the fully funded emergency fund and kind
of keep that there um and then make
student loan payments keeping that uh
full emergency fund in checking so I you
know either way he would be fine with
what I think is best okay well that's
what I would do I mean obviously because
you guys could be debt free by today
which is amazing and you free up that
payment yeah which is going to help you
save up faster but I and I do think Amy
it is so normal and this is how we are
in our marriage that one of you
naturally May kind of be more of a
scarcity mentality one of you is more
abundance my husband's more of the
scarcity kind of like okay let's save
let's be more conservative I'm more like
ah it's going to be fine we'll be okay
we're fine uh and I have more more of
that natural mindset but I think you
know you both can learn from each other
I just don't want you functioning out of
a place of complete fear and now where
you came from makes a lot of sense and
actually if you hold on the line
Christian I'd love to give her my book
know yourself know your money cuz I talk
about the childhood classrooms and how
much that dictates how you see and
handle money today is how you grew up up
but there's a healthy way you can you
can view that take those lessons that
are good lessons to learn that I don't
want to go back there which is very
valid but how do you shape it in a sense
that okay I don't have to feel like I'm
broke all the time or that I'm running
and I'm not getting anywhere because you
want a level of safety that you know
that money is a tool to create a life
you love and so that's what I want for
[Music]
you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz if
you want to check out some other shows
that we produced you can check out the
George camel YouTube channel and of
course the Rachel crw show on YouTube
and podcast and it's all on the Ramsey
Network app if you want to check that
out as well all right let's go to null
in El Paso Texas
nll did I get that right you did okay
wonderful how are you
doing uh doing all right taking it one
day at a time as best as I can how can
we help today what's going on so
essentially
uh my question is um you know I've been
listening to your show uh for a few days
I've been binging on it quite a bit now
um a couple year other podcast and and
uh you know I've been contemplating
bankruptcy uh it's been something that's
in my mind over the course of the last
couple months um and I'm just trying to
see if it's a better option to throw in
the towel and do that or to continue
attacking my debt aggressively um based
on what I've learned so far on the
show sorry to hear that well lay this
out for us how much do you make and how
much that do you
have okay so um I make approximately I
got two sources of income uh one is my
job which gives me rough about 81,000 a
year and then the other one's disability
compensation which is about 56,000 so
about 122,000 30,000 a year okay and
then as far as debt is concerned uh I
have about 80,000 in debt three of them
are personal loans well two of them are
personal loans one's my vehicle and the
rest is on credit card debt okay what
are the amounts for all those so the the
most expensive one is $388,000
um that one has about a $616 payment per
month um and it stretched out over 16 15
years what which which de is that that
one was a home improvement loan that I
took out um back in 2022 I was in the
middle of a remodel okay of my
house all right so I I took that money
for a remodel
okay and the second personal loan second
personal loan was a debt consolidation
loan it's roughly about $229,000
and then the third one is the vehicle
the my truck which is about $26,000 and
then the credit card debts roughly about
another 10 or
13,000 okay how much is the car worth
the
truck the truck is worth about
57k it's worth
$57,000 yes good and you owe
26 correct I like where this is going do
you see where this is
going I do see where your
recommendation's going to be explain to
me why you need this truck when you're
on the verge of
bankruptcy because I'm in construction
uh and I I I need the truck to be able
to get through the construction I just
checked Google they make $20,000
trucks they do um but I work in heavy
civil civil engineering construction so
I need something that can tow the amount
of weight that I need to be able to tow
and you're telling me there's no $25,000
truck that can tow that
amount probably so it's probably going
to be about 15 years old I'm okay with
that you're on the verge of bankruptcy
you just told
us you got here because you were
unwilling to have delay gratification
sacrifices weren't made and you made
some poor financial decisions and this
is the one on the list that you can undo
if you're willing to drive a 15-year-old
truck for a season so that you can avoid
bankruptcy
okay what's the truck
payment it's uh 583 a month so you would
have an extra 600 bucks a month to go
toward your
debt correct yes I mean do realize that
if if you're going to file bankruptcy
they're going to liquidate and get as
much as you know yeah possible anyway so
I mean this this this could all be on
your terms and it's going to be
uncomfortable and it's not going to look
the way that you've been handling your
money but something has has to change so
of course your life is going to look
different if you start making different
decisions with money and and it's not
going to be easy um because I mean a
little bit of the easy route is is the
debt route you kind of can get what you
want when you want it and you know
that's how majority of people live but
you're finding that it's causing stress
you're calling us for a reason because
you're not happy with where you are
financially so something does have to
change so your mindset around money
regardless of
work and construction and weight I mean
all of that like if you're in this
desperation part you know if you get to
this place in your life you're willing
to do anything like anything and I don't
I don't know if you feel that or want to
experience
that I just been through a lot of
suffering over the last year
um and it's not necessarily the whole
truck thing it's just yeah what's what's
been going on
the what caused me to to make all these
poor financial decisions I suffered a
traumatic event back in November 2022
when my son passed away oh sorry and so
that caused me to sell my house uh and
when I sold my house it was in the
middle of a
remodel um and I ended up being upside
down about $18,000 so I had to pay
$188,000 to sell a house um and then I
moved my daughter and I across the
country to bring my my son to his his
birthplace
to bury him um and it had to start all
over again so that's what caused me to
take out you know the that consolidation
loan for 27 or
$29,000 um and I I had a paid off truck
my truck was paid off I had a 2500 Ram
that was paid off and I traded that in
to get this vehicle because it was a 4x4
and it had more pooling power
um I hear you iend buy I had to buy
another house uh but it wasn't a house I
bought a mobile home that was another
$121,000 uh there so you know I I I
spent a couple hours on on the budget
app yesterday that the every dollar uh
spent app and for some reason it's
telling me that I have $2,600 worth of
margin every month left over um that's
with your minimum debt payments all of
your expenses that's what it should be
that's yeah I mean I put everything in
there all the payments that I'm making
still says I got $2,600 and don't get me
wrong I I've paid off close to about
3,000 $3,500 worth of credit cards full
credit cards in the last 30 days and you
know just just trying to to do what the
Ramsey method is telling me to do um you
know and I'm putting $40 away every
every week in savings to try to get to
that thousand savings to you know in my
underwear Dr te to keep it there for a
rainy day um well outside of the truck I
added it up I mean if you sell the truck
you'll have $80,000 in Consumer Debt
based on what you told us yes and so you
had said 80 at the top but you got 80
plus the $26,000 truck loan that puts
you at 6 figures in debt and I'm trying
to help including it what's that that's
including it that's including it the
26,000 what was the first loan you said
the home improvement loan 38,000 38,000
29,000 plus 29 plus 10 29,000 plus 13 in
credit card
26 yeah then according to credit card is
telling me I got 13 uh in credit cards
but and I'm telling you with a
calculator it's coming up at 80 and
that's without your car
loan so I just want you to have a real
picture of what your finances are at and
that's why I'm so desperate to get you
to get rid of this truck and downgrade
to number one free you of $26,000 today
before your truck goes underwater almost
every call people are underwater on
their truck so when you said this truck
is worth 57 026 I was doing back flips
because it gave me some some hope that
you can get out of this faster than you
think and if you do that and then do the
debt snowball every extra dollar outside
of food utilities uh shelter
Transportation insurance goes toward
that 80,000 you have remaining smallest
to largest balance I think you can get
out of this you make great money you're
a smart guy who works hard and and and
know that I mean from that information
that you just gave us about this last
year which is just the most horrific
thing that I could ever imagine is is
losing a child so I can't even I can't
even imagine what that grief does
there's a there a fog that is there and
when you make financial decisions
usually in that time soon after
something like that happens they're
always they're sometimes not the best so
that's not to guilt or to shame you
that's to kind of free you to say hey
yes you as you look back you're like w
those may not have been the best
decisions I don't blame you for that
because of what you walk through but I
do want to make sure that there's a
level of healing that you're getting
from this um and that the money is that
secondary piece but I do um I pray that
for you no I'm so sorry and yeah if you
stay on the line Taylor's going to pick
up and we'll give you John delon's book
and Total Money
[Music]
Makeover
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz this
hour got something new in the Ramsay
store for you guys Dave Ramsey just came
out with a brand new quick read book
called real estate the Ramy way subtitle
how to make home ownership a blessing
not a burden and uh this is a quick read
book so you can see on the camera it's
very small it's about I don't know 60 70
Pages yeah there we go 62 pages and it's
a great read that includes Dave's
Decades of experience with real estate
he got started at 18 years old he's been
in the game he owns a lot of it and he's
helped a lot of people buy sell and
invest the right way with proven
strategies and so he can help you avoid
some costly mistakes and pitfalls and uh
from start to finish you're going to get
a clear plan to help you buy sell and
invest in ways that will help you build
wealth and leave a legacy and he's going
to give you some hope that home
ownership is still possible for those
renters out there and a home can become
your biggest asset it can be a blessing
when done the right way so get your copy
at ramsy solutions.com Store gift it to
some people in your life who are maybe
about to buy or sell or want to invest
and uh enjoy enjoy the new book from
Dave Ryan joins us up next in Denver
Colorado Ryan how can we help
today hey how's it going thanks for
taking my call sure so my question today
is um with interest rates and home
prices so high right now uh is it a bad
idea for me to continue to rent and am I
making a long-term poor decision if I
choose to continue to rent right now are
you ready to buy financially let's say
regardless of the interest rate as you
look at what the payment would
be yes I I am ready to buy financially
but um it would cause me to violate one
of these rules that I have developed
which has allowed me to save and live
comfortably which is live off of one
income between me and my wife we live
off of the lesser of the two incomes um
but unfortunately because I live in
Denver Colorado these house prices are
just astronomical it's ridiculous so lay
out your financial picture and we'll let
Rachel be the judge here what is your
income and do you have any debt
uh my income is around $300,000 a year
is that household income I that's
household income okay uh and I have zero
debt amazing and how much do you have
saved for the down payment
Alone um so I'd be using a VA loan which
doesn't require down payment but um if
we needed a down payment it wouldn't be
a problem to do about 20% so okay give
or take I mean around maybe 20 to 50,000
do you have a disability
rating uh I do have a disability rating
so would that wave the funding fee with
the VA
loan uh I haven't looked into it um I
didn't have my disability rating
whenever I bought my my previous home
which has been sold but um I'd have to
look into it because the VA loan it can
be a good deal if you get the funding
fee waved if not I would go with a
conventional 15year fixed right loan
okay allowing people to get into a house
with 0% Equity is a really bad
plan yeah yeah and the 15year loan I
mean I it would push our home payment up
just so high and right now our rent is
uh is around 2100 a month and then we're
saving all of my income every month and
putting it towards retirement and
Investments so I so what is your take
home pay every month between the two
incomes um um I think it's right around
I I'll be honest with you I've never
really sat down and calculated it just
because we live off the one income the
other one is just savings but I think
it's right around uh
like 20 something thousand do wow that's
amazing yeah I mean Ryan I think one of
the goals for you guys though would be
to buy a home because you can't you're
renting forever there ends up being you
know that that point where you end up
yeah throwing your money away and and
renting is something that we encourage
people to do especially if they're not
financially ready to purchase a home um
if they haven't purchased home but they
have a lot of debt I mean there's
reasons to rent 100% of the time but
once you get to a place financially um
you know there there's a point that it's
wise to then step
into a home and to be able to say yeah
we're building Equity this is a big part
of our financial picture and if you guys
wanted to wait some and and have more
saved that it makes you feel more
comfortable that's totally fine I we
have people on the show that save for
five seven years and buy home in cash
you know and that's great too I mean as
long as you have a plan that you're
working towards and I just wouldn't want
completely the interest rate which
obviously does affect the payment um I I
just don't want the housing market to be
the thing that completely is the it's
the only Compass you have when buying a
home because I want you guys and your
finances to be the reason why you're
purchasing a home so a lot of people try
to kind of play the real estate game and
they're waiting and um you know and the
fear is too that when interest rates
drop or if they do we're hoping they do
that everyone who's been waiting to buy
a house pent up demand yeah I mean it's
they're going they're all going to jump
in and then prices are going to continue
to rise so I mean honestly the best time
to buy a house in my opinion right now
if you're ready is now um but I
understand financially if you guys are
like hey we want less of a yeah less of
a Down P we want more of a down payment
less of a monthly payment and we're GNA
we're going to spend another 24 months
to get there that's okay that that's
your goal that you guys are working
towards but I just don't want the idea
of the housing market driving that
decision does that make
sense yeah it does make sense and you
know to be honest I'm just scared that
uh if we have to go to uh using two
incomes to afford the house God forbid
something ever happens with my job or
something like that it would almost be
unaffordable yeah I mean and that's yeah
and that's a that's a fair place to be
for sure and that's why we want you to
have an emergency fund as well as you
enter home ownership because if
something were to happen you'll at least
have money in the bank to be able to
help cash flow that mortgage payment um
for a few months and so that that is one
thing that will help and and the yeah
and and I think the reality of being out
of work unless it's completely your
decision in my opinion um for for six
months or for five months or something
like that it's not going to happen
you're probably going to find another
job and have some source of income
coming in you know um but yeah so I mean
again it's a little bit of that risk but
if you guys want to be patient and wait
or maybe Ryan you guys look and say
we're going to get something way smaller
than what we were expecting or maybe
it's a condo it's you know what I mean
that that there's something else that
you purchase that may not be exactly
what you're thinking right now um and
again I don't want to rush you guys into
anything because I don't think that
there's a panic but I do want you guys
at some point to get into the game
because I think it's just a great
picture I think it's a great part of
your financial picture long term what
price point are you guys looking
at you know I'm I'm honestly willing
we're willing to buy a home or a condo
or an apartment that uh we don't see
ourselves living in long term maybe the
next foreseeable future yeah but um
there's really nothing on the market
around here that's not5 or $600,000 that
you're 5 or 600,000 your your monthly
payment would be I mean near $4,000 a
month which is just but you guys are
making you know let's say you're after
after tax but before other deductions
like investing you guys are probably
making 22 Grand
right yeah something we recommend 25% of
your take-home pay on that 15-year fixed
I've got the numbers right here you buy
a $600,000 house 20% down 15year fixed
with current interest rates it's 4600
bucks you guys can afford that that's
under 25% of your take-home pay so I
wouldn't make this decision based on one
income because the reality is you guys
make
$22,000 take-home pay and that's okay I
know it sounds scary but you guys make
an amazing income compared to the
average
American yeah yeah I guess it it does it
just so while it's doubling your rent
and that's scary it's also still a small
portion of your world and I don't think
you're going to be out of work that long
I mean what what do you do for a
living I'm an attorney okay there's
always going to be attorney work out
there we live in a very litigious
Society you know that you make good
money doing it and so you don't have a
super volatile job where you're going to
be out on the street for a year or two
where the industry shuts down so I think
we need to put push away that fear and
get into the real estate game yeah when
we're able and I'll I'm going to send
you a copy of Dave's new book real
estate the ramay way hopefully it'll
give you some confidence as you begin
this journey facts are your friends Ryan
and what George just laid out are the
facts your fear is understandable but
it's not reality so it's not happening
right the job loss and all of that so
focus on the facts that's great you guys
are in an awesome position well done
you're doing it the right way my man all
right that puts this hour of the Ramsey
Show in the books my thanks to my
co-host Rachel Cruz everyone in the
booth keeping the show float and you
America thank you for listening we'll be
back before you know
[Music]
it
[Applause]
[Music]
n
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel joined by
Ramsey personality and bestselling
author Rachel Cruz and we are here for
you this hour
aa825 5225 call us up we'll talk about
your life and your money we encourage
you we'll talk you off a ledge whatever
you need we're here for it opal kicks us
off in DC opal welcome to the
show hi guys thank you for taking my
call sure how can we help
today um so I am recently out of the
military and I currently go to school
full-time while working my goal is to
apply for medical school next year but I
want to graduate with no student loan
debt um so my question would be is would
Airbnb arbitr be a good idea for an
additional
income anytime the word arbitrage is
spoken out loud a puppy stops wagging
its tail oh my gosh you know what I
mean it's very
risky and I assume you know that because
you're calling us saying is this a good
idea I do um where do you get the idea
that this is going to be the
ticket um well I work part-time right
now while going to school and I'm a
reservist
still and I guess I I'm just looking for
a way to up my income but I don't really
have the time um because of everything
that I'm doing okay and to make sure
we're on the same page about the
definition of Arbitrage here you're
talking about hey I rent from a landlord
and then I'm going to list this place
that I'm renting on Airbnb and then I
will make a spread so if I'm paying
1,200 bucks a month in rent I'm going to
make 1,600 bucks through Airbnb net of
fees and I'll make that $400
spread yes correct okay uh number one
it's hard to find any landlord who will
agree to this and number two doing it
behind their back is what's known as
illegal and so that there in lies the
biggest problem is just finding a
situation subleasing is even hard at
times to even find the sub leas but let
alone short-term rentals I mean that's a
yeah it would be difficult to find and
there's so much risk with that there's
so much risk of the turn over of having
somebody there for a night or two or a
week at a time and then you would be the
one talk about a part-time job unless
you pay a management company if you
found a way to do this then they're
going to take majority of the of the
spread anyway so um what's hard about
this is it's one of those ideas that get
spread especially on social media where
it feels because it sounds so good it
sounds easy you don't even need to own
property and you can have passive income
yeah and to your point Opel you're like
I don't have a lot of time but listen if
if it really worked everyone would be
doing it everyone would be doing it but
they're not and for good reason either
because they legally can't they can't
find a landlord that will do it and or
you actually weigh out the reality of
real life when you do this and it's not
worth the risk because then if you end
up getting on the hook for this
rent you know if you don't have anyone
for two months I mean I mean there
there's just so many cases so many
things happening and where do you live
so it's one of the are you going to live
with these
strangers No I um I live in a camper I
bought I bought a camper and that's
that's what I'm living at a fulltime
currently um so I don't rent or have a
mortgage or anything so was your plan to
say I'm going to get in touch with a
landlord I'll never even live there I'm
just going to say hey I see you have
this place for rent would you be willing
to let me rent it out on Airbnb on your
behalf while paying you
rent
yeah I mean you can try that I I have
high suspicions that almost no one will
go for that and there's also a lot of
laws and regulations with the rent opal
you you would be stuck still you would
have to pay that if nobody was was going
to be living in
it and the liability that expense who
takes on the
liability I would um I just figured that
I'm I live I just moved here um so I I
live in a in a city now that I thought
it might be possible but I'm hesitant
obviously which is why I'm asking but
legally you can't take liability for the
entire house because you don't own the
house and so they've got their own
homeowners insurance you're paying
renters insurance which only covers your
stuff inside and so there's so many
problems with this legally that I don't
think it's a wise move um even if you
could do it I think there's just still
way too much risk and there's better
ways to make 400 bucks a
month okay and then so piggy backing off
of that um so my goal is to go and
graduate medical school debt free um I
guess like what do you recommend my
steps that I take towards that are where
are you at financially now do you have
any debt do you have any money
saved um yeah so I'll be done with baby
steps two and three this month oh great
congratulationses that's huge and how
much schooling do you have so
far um I have about a year and a half
left with my undergrad and I'll apply
for medical school next year okay and
are do you have any family helping out
with covering college or is it all on
you no it's uh the military is paying
for everything oh wonderful even for
medical school how does that work it
only covers through
undergrad yeah so it the military will
pay for 3 or for four years of your
undergrad but it doesn't it doesn't
account for medical school because
medical school is obviously more
expensive sure so so the military will
pay for um almost half of medical school
oh wow but the other but the other half
is is the half that I'm concerned about
okay and have you priced out different
schools let's say the most affordable
medical school if you got into that
school what would it
cost um probably around
$200,000 just for the other two years or
other half that is
needed yes you your half is 200 or total
yes uh my half would be 200 and how many
years a medical school is four years but
I would get two years paid for and then
I would be responsible for the you're
saying the most affordable medical
school is 400
grand um no I might have to go back and
run some numbers but the ones that I I
would was doing research on um was about
80 80 grand a year okay okay so maybe
closer to 160 is what you might
owe yes so I would start looking at that
and see hey can I maybe I'll take a year
or two and work and save up every penny
I can and get some roommates and can you
work in between what would you be doing
in your field after undergrad
um so for my undergrad my degree is in
Prem medicine I currently work part-time
as a physical therapy tech and then I'm
I'm in the reserves as well um and I
door Dash on the side just as a side
hustle great so what are you making
through all of
that um about 52,000 a year that's
awesome and what kind of doctor do you
want to
be uh emergency medicine okay yeah
that's great um well you're in a great
position considering half of it's going
to be paid for by the military so I
would do anything that I can to save up
and like you said cash flow this even if
it's pausing it for a year if I have to
but always remember that OB when you
when we go into a doctor's office we're
not looking to see where they went to
school and so we get stuck on the
Pedigree so easily and especially with
higher degrees like this law school
medical school go to the cheapest one
you can find that would be my suggestion
thanks so much for the call this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campell joined by Rachel Cruz the
number to call is AAA 825
5225 well Rachel this was big news that
I think people should know about cuz it
probably not making headlines on TV but
this is from a Yahoo article mother of
all data breaches 26 billion records
were leaked and this includes users of
LinkedIn X venmo and more and this could
cause a huge in targeted cyber crime so
not the most fun news but good for
people to know to stay protected out
there so this article says if you use a
computer your data likely got leaked in
what researchers have called the mother
of all data breaches 20 brands have had
over a 100 billion leaked records with
the largest being 10 cents 1.5 billion
more familiar Western to Western
consumers LinkedIn X venmo canva Apollo
Adobe also were hit and they're saying
that the majority of the population have
been affected my gosh that's frightening
yeah so experts are saying to be on high
alert for increased targeted cyber crime
and it should be noted that usernames
and passwords were included in the leak
and this is very dangerous because some
people use the same password for
everything I don't know who that would
be right there she's next to me yeah
this but think about it you have my if
you knew my password you can get into
all of Rachel's life Rachel told me her
password the other day just willy-nilly
for fun I did I don't know why but she
just straight up told happy hour episod
it was great I know you're not supposed
to do you have a bunch of different
passwords are you safe like that yeah I
mean for the most part there's there's
definitely some crossover I'm not Psy
James our producer of the show is the
biggest privacy nerd so I know he's got
like some crazy formulas like we'll
never guess James I played the fifth
it's not James 123 I can guarantee you
that but this is important to note
period throw a dang it we got him
Rachel so if they get let's say your
Netflix account information well these
hackers are smart enough to go oh that's
probably the same for banking
information and email accounts so that's
their my question is for these hackers
if you were a hacker George and they
have billions billions here you're like
this is like winning the lottery what's
the chances I get targeted that's kind
of what I'm asking well Rachel you're
assuming they're sitting there
physically typing each one they have
computers okay fine whatever that are
trying do that you know millions of
these a day probably okay so what do we
do we're checking vinmo we're I mean
that's the biggest one for me I don't
have LinkedIn well here's the thing you
need to uh be usually they're sending
emails letting people know that they
were part of a that canva is a design
app oh yeah don't have that y ra
Rachel's like I'm not touching that so
artisticness is not my goto they can
compromise multiple services in just
moments and so that's the scary part but
here's what we do go into vinmo and you
want to just what you're just you're
just checking and just making sure
there's no activity going on check I I'm
always V you know Vigilant check your
bank account once a day just to make
sure that all the transactions there are
things that you actually did what just
came up on my vinmo George camel wants
to be friends I requested Rachel and
Veno it was a big moment Big Show your
screen on the screen it just says George
camel wants to be friends can never be
too request accepted thank you Rachel
that meant a lot you're welcome so
here's what you can do um obviously you
can turn on two Factor authentication
that's one of the best ways to stay
protected that's where it's like I need
toel a text to verify the other thing
you can do is make sure that you're
using secure Wi-Fi you're not logging
into public sites on public Wi-Fi you
know if you're at of Starbucks and
you're logging into your bank account
through that public Wi-Fi that puts you
at risk there but the best thing you can
do and this is something that every
Ramsey team member has because we
believe in it that much it's ID Theft
Protection Yep this isn't quite
insurance but it's uh we we get ours
through Xander every team member has it
covered if you work here and I've I've
had to deal with this before Rachel with
identity theft and Xander yes they
worked with me to restore all of my
financial life back in order fight the
fraud so nice having someone else do it
it takes hours and hours and hours to
figure this out so ID theft protection
and it's needed in 2024 oh absolutely
like it it should be a must for this
it's not very expensive yeah no this um
it's so nice Xander takes care of all of
my insurance needs but ID theft is a
great one it's like six or seven bucks a
month and for a family it's like 12
bucks a month to get your whole family
covered and includes restorative sour um
Services Recovery Services up to a
million dollars in stolen funds so this
is not a big pitch for Xander but there
is something you can do about it and
that is get ID theft protection and uh
they do a great job with that I got an
email today and it was like ID theft
alert and it shows you what email was
compromised and what the source was were
you one of these you got 100% I mean
this is saying the entire population was
essentially affected no I know but that
email was it because of this breach I
don't know that's a good
question I imagine I'm going to be
getting more of these alerts so anytime
that happens that's the world we live in
now check those accounts change the
password on those and keep it secure y
spooky stuff Rachel yeah it's well it's
the world we live in as I'm like so much
is done online right I'm like that's
where that's where're going good shout
out for another service they're not
affiliated with us but it's called
privacy.com and they create virtual
debit card numbers that you can use when
shopping online cuz people always say
well Rachel I need my credit card
because I need to stay safe online like
no there's easy services to use it
creates a virtual debit card number tied
to or you can just use a debit card yes
but people are worried about using the
debit card because if something happens
it's their money taken out of their
account so the virtual debit card option
is really cool through privacy.com all
right on to something better Nicole is
in Newark New Jersey Nicole how are you
today hi I'm doing good how can we help
hi yes um I'm calling because I'm um
working to try and get out of debt and
one of the question I have is about U my
car lease that I have so um I have a
lease and it's 18 months left on it it's
$610 a month um that's a nice car you're
driving um not that fancy it's a Hyundai
Tu wow that's a big old lease payment
usually that's a Caray for most people
okay so 18 months left 610 a month
what's what do you know the buyout
amount um right now would be about
30,000 okay and how much money do you
have right
now in savings I have 12,000 you know
that's kind of my emergency fund okay
and do you have any other
debt yes I do um I have a mortgage um
that's 300,000 and I have another loan
which is 29,000 is like a personal
loan um it's I got my gutters and
windows
done okay and you're wanting to get out
of the lease is that what you're asking
what's the best way to get out well I
want to save money and reduce the
payment so I figured maybe getting out
the lease might be the best option or um
I've been advertising to try and do a
lease takeover um not sure if I'll find
anyone but want advice on maybe what
other options would be well there's only
three ways the first is early lease
termination which is going to come with
a whole bunch of fees the second one is
the one you mentioned a lease transfer
which involves finding someone else to
take over your lease which is like
trying to find someone to buy your time
share very few people want to take this
burden off of you and onto them and the
third option is the one that we
recommend most often which is the lease
buyout where you'd pay the difference
between the lease payoff amount and the
current value of the car and so that to
me is going to be your best bet do you
know what the car is worth
uh 24,000 they said
okay so you're it's a little bit
underwater
essentially yes so if you came up with
six you could have the difference to
cover
it if you were able to sell it
essentially cuz I'd recommend that to
sell it and you got 12,000 in savings
yeah so you could do that
option but you'd have to sell it then
you'd have to turn around and buy
another car
though yeah I could live a few months
um without a car as I have a job close
to me that I could just take the train
oh good um that's what I would the New
Jersey life right there public
transportation that's a
blessing yes yes so would you recommend
me um doing the buyout completely first
or trying to find a buyer and then you
know working them both together how
would you recommend doing that yeah I
mean if you can do it all kind of
simultaneously that'll be the cleanest
option um but okay it's you're you don't
have the title and so you're going to
have a hard time selling the car without
the title so you're going to need to
tell them hey I'm in a lease right now
I'm trying to sell it I would contact
the dealer and let them know what's
going on and see what the best option is
to have that functionality
work okay but the least buyout is your
best bet and uh it's there's going to be
some stupid taxs Nicole it's going to
hurt but I'm proud of you for wanting to
turn this around and being willing to
make the sacrifices
needed yes thank you you got this this
is the ram
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz and
in the ramsy solutions Lobby on the
debt-free stage we've got some new
friends Nicholas and devony welcome guys
hi hi thank you for having us absolutely
where are you guys from so we're from
ker Alabama which is about 30 Mi south
of Birmingham wonderful and all the way
here to your debt free scream how much
did you guys pay off we paid off
$232,200 wow and how long did that take
four years nice wonderful and what was
the range of income during that time uh
we started at 82,000 and then up to
163,000 whoa that's incredible what was
the big jump well um our our buddy Ken
Coleman would be proud I took full
advantage of the great resignation
during
Co nice so um we didn't have that big of
a shovel or not as big as we' like and
so I just went job searching and in less
than a week uh I found a job and it
doubled my salary wow oh my gosh so are
you one income family um sort of sort of
when we paid off the house and she can
go deeper into in a minute but when we
paid off the house uh she wasn't the
happiest at her job and and I said you
know what I'm paying off we're paying
off the house today you can put in your
two
weeks okay so the 238 was the house mhm
well it was credit cards car loans
student loans in the house everything in
the house congratulations you guys
that's incredible wild that's incredible
so four years ago you guys had some
credit cards you had the mortgage you
were living normal what happened to get
you on this ramsy journey well if if you
uh if you look back at it that's right
when Co first hit and um you know we had
friends family you know we just kind of
saw people you know struggling and then
you know you turn on the TV you see
people losing their jobs losing their
livelihoods and uh we thought we were
safe but we just kind of said what if
you know and then we dug deeper into our
finances and we were like wow we're in a
mess um and so we started chipping away
at the credit cards um we did side
Hustle
uh she was making she started making
like hair bows for little girls selling
those um I did door dash for a while um
and we started selling stuff just around
the house and and Rachel you'll relate
to this any old kids toys that we could
find that were in one
piece we we' put on Facebook Marketplace
good for yall so we just we just made it
happen and did whatever we could uh to
get out dang wow so there was sort of a
pandemic Panic you guys went we're we
could be like just like those guys 3
seconds from now let's get our Affairs
in order here yeah and I prior to co I
was working from home anyway so like I
was safe but I always think the worst
thing is going to happen so I'm like
what if I lose my job what if we both
lose our jobs sure sure and so we're
like we need to we need to get out isn't
it amazing how you can carry that risk
of debt for so long and until something
really shakes it like a pandemic or
something do you realize oh my gosh it
is risk like these car loans like all
this Deb that we're carrying it is a
level of risk that some of people are
used to but the moment you start saying
wow this really is a part of our lives
that we want out it's it's incredible
absolutely and she's you know I'm the
saver so it wasn't hard for me to get on
board and she's the spender and so you
know she's the one where it's like every
day in Amazon boxes totally the Amazon B
lives at our house so so deonie how was
this for you this four years was it was
it hard was it once you got onard boor
and you guys were working together you
were seeing the progress it was good but
like how did it how did it feel overall
yeah I mean it was definitely a little
different at first um especially cuz
right around that time our daughter was
born and I had my first daughter and of
course I wanted her to have all the cute
girl things and all stuff like that so
um it was definitely hard at first and
um then I stopped I was like okay like
she doesn't need this and then I started
like Nick said I started making bows and
stuff for girls hairs and she did not
like them at all she wouldn't keep one
on her head so I was like okay this
there's no point to buy this stuff so um
I definitely got there it took a little
bit but sure once I started then I was
like oh like this is great oh my gosh
did you guys know about Ramsay and the
baby steps at this point how did you
find out about this so um I just uh when
the pandemic first hit you know I pretty
much just Googled you know getting out
of dead and and how to you know how to
clean up this stuff and um and then I
bought The Total Money Makeover uh
Reddit in one weekend I think and then
we just kind kind of just snowballed
from there literally amazing that's
incredible so great okay so what would
you say to a young family that's
listening and they have the car loans
and the credit cards and they're just
normal living life but they're feeling
like oh my gosh we want to change what
would you say the key of getting out of
debt is yeah I I mean I think for us I
mean you look at us we're in our 30s and
we did this you know we we hear people
all the time younger people it's harder
to live these days you can't buy a house
you can't do this but they're also
hundreds of thousands of dollars in debt
and it's like Well Control what you can
control and so I mean I mean Rachel you
know you were born the year your parents
filed for bankruptcy George you went
from negative net worth to a millionaire
in 10 years you look at us we both grew
up in less than ideal situations her
parents got divorced when she was young
my parents got divorced when I was young
my dad passed away when I I was 8 years
old and he didn't have any life
insurance and so I was raised by a
single mother no help just trying to
figure it out so if we can do it anybody
can do it so good that's inspiring and
it's just the belief you can yeah
absolutely and that's it it's to believe
that you can that's incredible you and
in your early 30s on your way and baby
step seven what's the house worth so uh
well we bought um in January 2018 right
before the housing market just went
Bonkers good time to buy so yeah so I
mean we we paid less than 200,000 for
our house about 190 and there's homes in
our neighborhood selling for over 300
now wonderful that's incredible and so
you got that paid off and you've been
investing in retirement yeah yep yep so
now we're we're um uh we're doing 15%
we're still trying to save up for the
kids college and and all that and we're
also cash flowing um in international
adoption right now too so this is not
our complete family that's great we yeah
we were hoping the adoption would be
finalized when we came here but um it
just kind of you know worked out this
way but uh um but yeah so we're doing
that saving up for the kids college
investing and you know we were at a
negative net worth a significant
negative net worth four years ago and
now we're on the path to be
multi-millionaires unbelievable
unbelievable fun and when you have the
margin to do things like you guys get to
just cash flow this adoption with joy on
your face instead of stress because
you've also got payments so I love
when you turn money from an obstacle
into a tool it's amazing how your life
changes and I'm so proud of you guys for
being a living breathing picture of that
yeah absolutely and I told her you know
she stuck with me these past four years
you know and I know it wasn't the
easiest thing so when we paid off the
house I said you know you just pick
anywhere on the map and we'll go there
for a trip oh so where you going to go
we don't even know yet we we don't bring
map out Rachel's going to throw a dart
yeah we we've talked about you know know
Europe and you know going or going on a
cruise or whatever we we don't know
we're yeah we'll probably go on a couple
trips one with the kids and one with
just us to so love it I know and you
have the kids with you bring them up
what are their names and ages uh so
Brantley is our oldest he's seven and
then Cambry is h four
oh look how cute I Hope they've been
practicing for the Dee screen color CED
with the lavender outfits they look
fantastic for those of you can't see get
a family photo after this is done that
is wonderful here we go guys we got
Nicholas and devony and Brantley and
Camry
$232,000 paid off in four years house
and everything making 82 up to 163 count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
all right Camry you ready you ready to
lead us off all right go ahead in the
mic two one we're de
free wo
W that might win the award for cutest de
free scream I've ever seen my gosh I
just teared up I like I was like oh my
God what performance and we've got a
special gift for you guys two every
dollar premium gift cards for a one-year
subscription you can use one you can
renew it that you can give it away to a
friend to get them started on the
journey and George and just hearing
their stories of even the change that
they've made from their childhood to now
what these kids are going to experience
it's absolutely incredible Beyond
finances early 30s no mortgage
incredible in 4 years well done you guys
well done it's possible for you America
are you willing to make those kinds of
sacrifices for 4 years I can do just
about anything for that amount of time
and I know you can too it is worth it
look at that couple look at that Journey
this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day Ephesians 4:32
be kind and compassionate to one another
forgiving each other just as in Christ
God forgave
you speaking of forgiveness Rachel
forgive me for these two quotes Taylor
Swift said you play stupid games you get
stupid
prizes only to be outdone by Travis
Kelce who said wow if you don't care
about the guy next to you one you're a
terrible teammate two you're never going
to win ah you byy stupid games I think
it's you win stupid prizes well I think
we need to someone on the team is
getting in trouble now Rachel knows her
t- Swift lyrics She also didn't invent
that straight from a pretty big fan so
you'll have to battle with her but we
we'll fact check it you play stupid
games you win super prize I'm pretty
sure that's what it is it's one of my
favorite lines play stupid games Win
stupid prizes do stupid stuff that's
what you're GNA win stupid things you
know and again she didn't kind like rap
what you SE she's basically quoting
scripture that's Rachel's mental
gymnastics right there that's what it
looks like y'all this is what I have to
deal with as a professional co-host of
the ramsy show this kind of ridiculous
justification it's true it's what we do
and Travis Kelsey y'all are funny that
was funny well done well done team we're
having a good time all right Ruby is in
Chicago Ruby welcome to the ramsy show
how can we help today oh thanks for
having me on here it's a pleasure what I
need help with is uh
whether should I uh pay my house off or
my car off or pay both off I love the
idea of getting rid of all your debt
Ruby yeah it's a great question okay
Ruby um how much how much money do you
have I have
$6,350 106,000 and where is that money
is that in retirement accounts is that
invested is that just in a checking
account it's just in the savings account
just a traditional savings account okay
and is this the money I guess you live
off
of uh no the money I live off of I I get
um
$633 a month and what's that
from that's from uh VA that's um my
husband was a veteran when he passed
away okay so that's guaranteed income
for the rest of your life yes wonderful
wonder and how old are you then I'm 73
okay and what's left on the
mortgage uh
76,000
463 and the car
loan
$22.33 uh you said $22 oh I'm sorry
22,33 okay I was like well we can pay
off $20 right quick okay so total you're
looking at about $98,000 you have 106 in
savings
is that does that include your emergency
fund in that
106 no it doesn't oh you have other
money well I don't have other money but
what I would probably do is save that
six months of uh money I would need if I
need it I would take 25,000 and just put
it aside for you know whatever and
savings yeah for your living expenses
Ruby how much extra do you have a month
you have 6,000 coming in do you have any
margin
I have uh 2,000 coming in after I pay
everything off 2,000 extra that you can
do what you want
with okay that's great this is wonderful
so you live on
4,000 um so a six-month emergency fund
really is
18,000 um of what you'll need for a good
for a good emergency fund and what I'm
seeing the numbers if you yeah if you
paid off everything it would leave you
8,000 and bank so that means you know
you would have 10,000 you would still
have to put to your emergency funds um
but I don't think I would do that quite
yet so so what I would probably do Ruby
if I were you I would go ahead and pay
off the
car if I were you and then I would save
over five months to get to
18,000 and then once you have 18,000
saved use the remaining of your savings
to pay off the house yeah okay that's
what I was thinking but I wanted some
confirmation yeah and you're in a great
position Ruby that's that's wonderful
exciting and you're going to free up
that mortgage payment which is going to
help you save up yeah how much how much
is that a
month it's only6
$693 a month what about your car payment
and that's and that's because um I don't
pay taxes okay what about your car
payment right
now my car payment is
$497 Ruby this is exciting do you know
what just is about to happen you're
freeing up 700 bucks and 500 bucks
you're going to have an extra $1,200 on
top of the 2,000 so you have 3,200 bucks
that you can use to then invest and save
and spend and enjoy your
retirement right right that's what I
want needed to know but I what I'm
planning on I think maybe within the
maybe next couple years to uh buy a
house but a cheaper house cuz I don't
need what I have now is a little too big
so you would downsize with
cash yes yeah you could definitely make
that move for sure I wouldn't go further
into debt by any means but I know you're
you're going to downsize so that means
yeah you'll have some Equity then to put
away as well when you decide to do that
which great what would your house sell
for about 400,000 awesome and you would
downsize to something smaller that's
let's say 300,000 or
350 probably more like 300 ,000 great I
love this plan this is wonderful so yes
what you're going to do is I'd pay off
that car loan today that's going to
leave you with 84,000 and then once you
have enough to have your full emergency
fund plus the rest of the mortgage go
ahead and just knock that mortgage out
completely pay extra on the principal
great congats wonderful situation I'm
proud of you Ruby you've done really
well well thank you thank you thank you
for calling into the show good day oh
you're welcome thank you thanks Ruby
what a wonderful call I love Ruby that's
and you know it's a cool reminder Rachel
Ruby 73 and a lot of people at that age
just go well I've got the mortgage I've
got the car payment I'm not going to do
anything about it right and so it's a
great reminder that it's not too late
that's right now her situation was great
cuz she had six figures sitting in
savings yes and has a great guaranteed
income but it's not too late even if
you're in your 60s your 70s we
scre are over AG spectrum of life and
Freedom's y that's exactly right and to
do something with that money that's
going to free up so much and for her
financially speaking Yeah it's an extra
$1,200 a month which is huge so good so
so and for a lot of people out there if
they paid off their mortgage and the
rest of their debt they'd have even more
than that coming in every month for sure
that's my plan and that's my hope for
everyone is to go into retirement with
zero debt including no mortgage payment
because it allows you to live off less
you don't need as much money Y and so
that Social Security is just icing on
the cake what you have in your
Investments and what that's making for
you every month to pull from is plenty
so it's a good reminder for people out
there but I I like Ruby's personality I
want to hang out with Ruby and just gain
some wisdom you know she's lived a she's
lived a good life you can tell you can
tell wow well this has been a fun show
Rachel I don't know if you enjoyed it as
much as I did
but it started off dark we had a lot of
heavy calls this show you know what I
mean and and I think it proves this is
why I love doing this and hosting this
show is you get people from every Walk
of Life every situation some situations
are just absolutely heartbreaking some
are hopeful with the debt-free scream
right you kind of get the whole gamut of
what's going on but the the thread that
we see continually through our callers
through the people that DM us on social
or comment or listeners or if we if
we're at a live event we meet you uh or
here on the Deb free stage or watching
the show like whenever we interact with
people doing this plan know regardless
of where they came from what they make
the amount of debt they have the number
one qualities they believe they can do
this and they believe that they can take
control of their money they believe they
can wake up every day make a different
decision from what they've made in the
past do something different to get a
different result and that hope it really
it sounds cheesy George but it really is
the thing I'm like that is the very
first step is that mindset with that
belief that that we can do this and for
some people it takes longer some people
shorter but it is possible yeah my
favorite stat from the millionaire study
we did was 97% of millionaires believe
they had control over their financial
destiny interesting it's amazing if you
think you have Agency on autonomy over
your life you're going to act like it
you're going to behave like it and so
that's what this show is all about we
want to give you hope and I don't care
if it's cheesy because life is too short
we going to to not though aren't we on
Sunday heck yeah Rachel so well that
puts this hour of the ramsy show in the
books thanks to Rachel Cruz all the
folks in the booth and new America
will'll be back before you know
[Applause]
[Music]
it
yeah